the Batman vs Superman Easter eggs that
flew over your head with the running
time of two and a half hours Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice has a lot going
on we've gone over all 153 minutes with
a fine-tooth comb and picked out the
best and biggest Easter eggs to give you
hints of what to look for in the movie
here's a spoiler build guide to all the
DC Comics goodies peppered throughout
the film one more time for anyone who's
not paying attention major spoilers
ahead still here great let's dive in
Darkseid is coming Bruce Wayne's
nightmare vision which occurs while he's
asleep at his bad desk hints that
something major looming on the PC movie
horizon fans of the comics will
recognize the flying creatures in this
scene as parademons the nasty comics
creatures who served the intergalactic
uber villain known as Darkseid you can
also see Darkseid - Omega symbol carved
into the ground at the beginning of
Bruce's vision and Luthor seems to
directly reference his impending arrival
when he threatens he's coming at the end
of the movie but that's not the only
hints of Darkseid presence we get out of
Batman vs Superman mother buys when
Wonder Woman takes a tour through Lex
Luthor's metahuman files we get our best
looks yet at the future members of the
Justice League including the flash
Aquaman and Cyborg in particular cyborgs
origin told via lab footage that shows
him being booted up for the first time
has even more to offer fans than just
the beginnings of a major superhero
that's because we can a look at what
seems to be a mother box a super
powerful supercomputer ripped right from
the pages of Jack Kirby's new god saga
just like Batman's vision of the future
the mother box has major ties with
Darkseid and the aliens of new Genesis
and apocalypse since it looks like
cyborgs creation has direct ties to New
Gods technology just like the new
version of his origin in the comics from
2011 expect the hero to play a pretty
big role in the DC extended universe
riddle me this
Batman's troubled past is felt more than
seen or discussed in Batman
Superman dawn of justice but Snyder's
fondness for referencing comics war can
be seen in the building where the
showdown between the two heroes goes
down if you look carefully you can spot
what looks a lot like some graffiti left
behind by the Riddler or perhaps some of
his henchmen
might we see him in future DC movies and
will Jim Carrey reprised the role cagey
beast
Lex Luthor has a high-ranking Hegeman
and Batman vs Superman named Anatole
kanai's him played by Kalin Moby and
although he doesn't look anything like
he does in the comics DC fans will
recognize that as the real name of the
villain known as cagey beast could we be
seeing two knives EV in a different form
later on considering his fate in this
movie getting exploded after Batman
shoots at the flamethrower he's wearing
on his back it's a good bet that he'll
be more inclined to wear something
closer to his comic book costume in
future appearances assuming of course he
hasn't simply been incinerated mercy
graves that's no ordinary employee
bringing Sods corpse to Lex Luthor fans
of Superman the animated series will
recognize the character of Mercy graves
played here by calico moto Luthor's
personal assistant and bodyguard she
became a fan favorite during the run of
the series and it's exciting to see her
brought to the big screen in such a
major movie of course unless we
misunderstood the scene where she's
inside the Senate building that explodes
about halfway through the movie we might
not get much more mercy in future DC
film flicks oh well metallo before the
movie came out it was rumored that
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice would
feature an appearance by metallo the
comics villain who goes from life as a
soldier to a life of crime after having
his body rebuilt with kryptonite powered
cyborg parts that didn't quite happen
probably because of how many other
details were crammed into its running
time yet if you watch the closing
credits you'll see that one of the
technicians demonstrating the effects of
kryptonite in Luthor's lab is named
Emmet Vale
which just happens to be the name of the
scientist who filled metallo watch for
the metal man to make his debut in a
future DC extended universe bill Jimmy
Olsen as much fun as Zack Snyder clearly
has calling back to the comics he isn't
above changing things up when it suits
him
case in point Jimmy Olsen's brief and
ultimately tragic cameo in Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice early in the
film when Lois travels through the
fictional country of Nairobi Africa for
a story she's accompanied by a
photographer who turns out to be a CIA
scoop and is quickly put to death by the
warlord she's interviewing according to
remarks Snyder made during his press
corps for the film that's actually Jimmy
Olsen
although Snyder didn't think there was
any room in the DC Cinematic Universe
for him the director decided putting one
of Superman's best friends in the movie
and killing him off would be a way to
have fun with the character Zod of
Pandora we saw a return from Man of
Steel's bad guy General Zod albeit in
the form of a corpse and then a CGI
monster while the trailers showed that
to be the case months before the movie
dropped the little robots inside the
Kryptonian ship did give us another cool
little Easter egg we find out that Zod
comes from the city of Kandor which is
better known to comic fans as the bottle
city of Kandor the capital city of
Krypton candor is shrunken and stolen by
the Superman villain Brainiac and is
added to his intergalactic collection of
artifacts after Superman and Brainiac
square off Kandor ends up under
Superman's protection at the fortress of
solitude hopefully we get a chance to
see a movie version of the classic
Superman villain with candor in tow The
Dark Knight Returns if you've watched
Watchmen you know that Zack Snyder likes
recreating comic panels in his film
adaptations and Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice is loaded with callbacks to
one of its biggest inspirations the
Frank Miller graphic novel The Dark
Knight Returns it starts early with the
movie's depiction of Bruce Wayne's
parents being killed a shot of Miss
Wayne's pearls around the muggers gun is
a direct lit from the book and continues
throughout the movie both in the
dialogue and in the way certain shots
are lined up more than anything however
man's coward armor which he wears during
the title fight with Superman is taken
straight from Miller's iconic series
Action Comics love him or hate him
Snyder definitely enjoys paying homage
to the comics one brief example comes
during an argument between Clark Kent
and Perry White at the office of The
Daily Planet
during which white tells Kent that he
can't report on the types of stories he
wants to cover because it's not 1938
anymore as any DC fan can tell you
that's the year Superman made his first
appearance in Action Comics number one
must there be a Superman the movies
action comics reference is far from the
only nod to the Man of Steel's print an
adventure during one seen the senator
played by Holly Hunter asks must there
be a Superman it's an interesting
question and one that directly points to
a 1972 issue of the Superman comic in
which our hero is forced to face a
Tribunal for his quote crimes against
humanity since the hero is instrumental
in the defeat of doomsday and the
foundation of the Justice League this is
a question that gets answered with a
resounding yes by the end of the movie
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to see more videos like
the one you just watch and leave us a
comment to let us know which Easter Egg
was your favorite and any ones that you
think should have made the list